manifestation impromptue après que la
direction ait voulue interdire les
débrayages spontanés pour envoyer
un message
augmente la charge de travail et force
les infirmières qui restent à faire
beaucoup de temps supplémentaires les
solutions ressources humaines ça prend
du temps former des infirmières donc on
est sur ça en attendant d'avoir plus
d'effectifs le temps supplémentaire
reste un problème et à légèrement
augmenter depuis trois ans ça représente
maintenant 8% du total des heures
travaillées dans le réseau de la santé
c'est presque le double de la moyenne
québécoise pour tous les autres domaines
mais dans 20 hôpitaux québécois les
heures supplémentaires dépassent 10% du
total Santa Cabrini à Montréal est en
tête avec 16% du total des heures
travaillées qu'ils sont en temps
supplémentaire à wake fiel dans nottaway
c'est 14%, plusieurs hôpitaux du 4 5 0
font partie du groupe dont le suroît ou
12% des heures sont faites en sortant
mais le temps supplémentaire
laboratoire bruyamment décréé par les
syndicats représentent moins de 1% du
total des heures travaillées c'est
peut-être juste 1% là mais c'est 18000
heures de travail forcé qui a été imposé
à chamer et plusieurs remèdes en cause
la fiabilité des chiffres du
gouvernement considérant que c'est
probablement la pointe de l'iceberg donc
on sait pas encore exactement comment y
compile ses statistiques et ses chiffres
globaux
occulte la réalité de certains
départements comme l'urgence et
l'obstétrique
[Musique]
infirmière sur le plancher dont souvent
il y en a 6 qui vont être en TS
obligatoires les négociations pour le
renouvellement des conventions
collectives avancerait lentement et vu
la colère de bien désinfirmières l'été
pourrait être plutôt chaud dans les
hôpitaux du Québec ici David gentil les
réseaux Canada Montréal